beaucoup de mime mais camara parce que
j'en ai fait beaucoup depuis sa maison
qui ont un talent fou c'est vrai il veut
et puis j'adore sont des gens qui sont
qui n'hésite pas à s'oublier pour être
un autre et c'est ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est que quelques fours dit
qu'un artiste sait tout faire
tu sais tout faire aujourd'hui c'est
tout fait à nîmes sait tout faire
mais un mille ne peut pas tout faire
un jour je devais me met quelqu'un qui
n'a rien à faire eh bien j'ai rien pu
faire parce que ne rien faire
ça peut se dire mais ça ne peut pas se
faire et depuis je ne pouvais pas dire
je ne pouvais pas le faire parce que le
personnage qui n'avaient rien à faire en
plus n'avait rien à dire
le directeur avait bien spécifié mme
avery surtout pensez bien ce que vous
avez à faire c'est à dire en fait penser
à rien et il avait ajouté surtout ne le
dit pas et je lui avais donné ma parole
de mines que je ne dirai rien
alors je suis entré sur scène comme ça
j'ai commencé à ne rien faire sans rien
dire ça à l'air de rien mais faut le
faire suffit pas de le dire
et près de salma plus je ne faisais rien
plus les gens disaient qu'est ce qui
fait le public n'est pas fou il voyez
bien faisait quelque chose mais comme
c'était rien ils demandaient ce que
j'étais venu faire et les critiques dans
la salle voyez bien que je ne faisais
rien et que je faisais bien et
s'attendait à plus
et moi qui les jeunes faisait rien je
pouvais pas faire moins les gens dans la
salle eux qui voyaient rien ils ont
commencé à trouver à redire au moins
faire un geste
avoir un bon mouvement dans ce que
voyant moi j'ai fait le solde reste que
pour espère mettre quelqu'un qui n'a
rien à faire
sans qu'on dise il en fait trop j'ai
fait un geste d'impuissance
alors les gens dans la salle qu'est ce
qui dit alors là j'ai rompu le silence
j'ai dû mesdames et messieurs mais je
n'ai rien dit qu'est ce que j'avais dit
là le directeur hinault
non seulement je paye un hymne à ne rien
faire il ne le fait pas mais en plus il
ne tient pas sa parole il parle il a dit
monsieur vous n'êtes même pas bons à
rien alors le lendemain dans la presse
quand android comme on dit les critiques
comme j'avais rien fait ils n'ont rien
dit mais en bien